he's Harold Reynolds friend of the show
Major League Baseball Network analyst
and a man who won not one not two but
three Gold Gloves and now wants to take
back one of those gold gloves talk to
Harold yesterday and I said why are you
taking the Gold Glove back nobody's ever
gonna see that thing and we put it on
display so people remember the greatness
of Harold Reynolds well to be factually
correct Dan said more people will see it
here than any other place okay I mean if
you want a big following man but if you
want to bring it home to the family and
you want to let the kids see it but you
have three of them I know but they're
all over the country I got one in
California my brother Larry's office and
I got one at Safeco Field okay so yeah
also you want one at home now who's
closer me or your brother Larry yeah
like who means more to you probably
Larry gets a Gold Glove look at that you
got any other memorabilia what's the
coolest thing you got uh the Roberto
Clemente award is pretty cool that's a
funny story all right it's probably
something I should do with your gold
glove cuz they used to give us a little
ball do you want to give me the Clemente
award I could do that you love it yeah
I'll bring that as I I loved Clemente
well it was used to be a little baseball
yeah and so then when Commissioner Selig
started holding the podium and they had
the announcement that the all-star get
at the World Series and all that it
became like the Heisman Trophy and so
I'm presenting it and I go I don't have
one that looks like that
and Commissioner Selig got me one so I
have the Heisman Trophy looking Roberto
it's really cool how big is it it's huge
it's like I mean that signifies a lot
the Roberto Clemente a tough one to give
up man but if you I think you should
keep that and give me the gold you know
ladies keep the gold glove because the
Clemente award signifies a whole lot
Gold Glove anybody can hardly work with
you're hard to work a little glove
anybody can win one knows I can leave
the glove how political is how political
was Gold Glove voting or is it still
because it felt that there were guys
that we're gonna get it whether they do
deserved it how did Rafael Palmeiro get
a Gold Glove one I know he played 25
games
that kind of that kind of wrote it it
used to be the coaches and the managers
who voted and clearly there was a
stronghold if you played a long time and
and and it was political at certain
times I don't know if it's as political
as it used to be we've thrown in so many
stats now that make no sense you know
I'm sitting here going he saved runs
saved well how do you know if a guy
saved a run or not if we're not really
looking at he'd of with a runner on
second and caught the ball and saved a
run so that's not an actual stat or use
er his range and what's Jeter an elite
fielder yeah he was you know what I look
at is he lead is he never missed the
ball but did he get to enough balls did
when he was younger when he was older he
didn't but here's the trick he was a
better fielder a Ron or cheater
I think Jeter was probably more
consistent you know a rod didn't miss
they didn't mean either one of them
missed many balls here's the key alright
and I played with Omar Vizquel we've
been talking about Omar best fielder of
all time first few years I play with him
diving all over the place because he
didn't know how to position himself and
then pretty soon he knew where to stand
everybody's like oh he doesn't have a
range anymore well you're not supposed
to be diving all over the place once you
figure out the lead well Ripken did that
to Ripken play great position late and
that's what I think the knock on Jeter
was as he got older he wasn't all over
the plane he didn't need to be he knew
where he's supposed to stand that's the
thing that I think people miss is a rod
gonna get married to JLo wow they're a
perfect couple
yeah they are I mean you think about
their you follow them on Instagram know
everybody that work comes to me and says
oh did you see this one
they're both neurotic about that stuff
they both have these personalities that
are so driven who's prettier oh she is
oh come on okay my bad he's pretty good
have you been out with him yet I met
them at the all-star game but going to
dinner with them here in the fall yeah
yeah yeah he's he's fallen he's he's
[ __ ] love yeah what a turnaround
though this guy went from suing the
league
suspended - he's doing the World Series
didn't happen though how did that
transformation happen with a Ron you
know I uh several people I think sat
down on him I think he got to the point
where he's like look am I gonna live in
this storm the rest of my life and I
think he really did a great job of
cleaning it up as far as getting in
front of people talking through the
folks he needed to meeting with the
commissioner with Tony petit II getting
the Fox with those people and really
just basically saying hands up I did it
let me change my my my thinking in my
way and he did a great job but return it
around and I thought he showed great
insight and a sense of humor on those
Fox broadcast I I thought that it became
must-see TV and and an a-rod you know
and Pete Rose and a-rod and Frank you
know had fun there yeah but I thought a
rod showed the ability to be great at
broadcasting he's selfless when you do
it you got to push the game out you
can't bring it back necessarily to you
all the time and a-rod I think was
always accused of making it about him
and now he's making it about the game
yeah well I think the interesting thing
is he's always been a guy thought he was
a coach as well you know I think he
looks at broadcasting like he's teaching
he's coach yeah so I think that's part
of what his personality is let me give
you the official introduction to Harold
Reynolds who is now going to leave his
gold glove here with us Major League
Baseball Network will exclusively
televise to American League Division
Series games this postseason you can
catch Harold on MLB tonight throughout
the postseason explain to the audience
where Aaron judge was the first half of
the season where he was when he had this
horrendous slump to where he is now as
we head into the postseason well I think
it's funny I did a breakdown on this
last night 16 he struck out a lot he
struggled I mean like half the a bats
his swing and missed I think he really
simplified it went back to what he did
in college and basically set his hands
in a position and swung the bat not a
lot of thinking season starts he takes
off he went through the struggling I
think part of the struggle was fatigue
you know he played all-star game home
run derby
strikes out 37 games in a row and then
the Yankees go you need a day off well
yeah he said I had one a while back and
then he really made a nice adjustment
he's starting to get his hands in front
of himself and getting them back where
he can read again so that's kind of the
quick analogy of what he's done but it's
been remarkable what pictures you know
people always Gale you know hitters in a
slump
well the pitchers job is they can be in
a slump - giving up home runs - Aaron
judge they have to figure out how to get
him out and I always say give me one
time two times through and then let me
see what pitchers are doing to you and
if they're not doing anything to you
then you're the real deal and then they
still have to try to find out what are
the whole Giancarlo Stanton I think has
been a great example of a guy who went
from being just a power hitter swing
hard and hit it - now he's become a
legitimate hitter starter in the strike
zone and what he can and can't do well
you look at judge he was sitting 3:30 at
the all-star break you know that's
pretty good but but watching him Dan
take batting practice at the all-star
game I was blown away
he had a ball off the roof in Miami and
balls he was heading to right field
looked like a left-handed pull hitter it
was unbelievable so I think he
understands I can hit the ball out
anywhere at any time to have that kind
of power and that strength so that
allows him to be able to manipulate the
strike zone a little bit more and nobody
can handle on what he can't and and as a
result he's done that I think Stanton's
been great for him because as a guy
watching another power hitter trying to
emulate what he does he's watched
Stanton realized with my great power I
can hit it out anywhere so Stanton
doesn't have to pull the ball you look
at Albert peoples now pulls when he was
younger he hit the ball out all over the
place now he's got a pull ball hit it
out the ballpark you know so the batting
average is gonna come down and so it's
it's gonna be fun watching judge he's
next couple years
explain what happened to the Dodgers boy
I fell apart I look at they played too
many lineups for me baseball is a game
of adjustments and when you can't make
that adjustment the next day because the
matchup doesn't look good on paper
you're gonna struggle and when they they
have a bunch of guys that are everyday
players it wasn't a bunch of utility
guys I said I'm only gonna play two or
three days they don't over expose me
you have everyday players playing in
that role you're gonna struggle
eventually I think that's what hit them
and now they're starting to get it back
together but they're not the big
favorite for me as I head into the
postseason who do you like I like the
Nationals in the merit in the National
League I really think what they did at
the all-star break that bullpen they put
together Bryce Harper's coming back he
had the flu last night's who didn't play
but they're gonna get him three or four
days of games and he'll be ready to go
but that that team that lined up was
complete I love their starting pitching
they got three guys I can do it in the
front in the American League it's gonna
be a flipping the coin it's gonna be
crazy I think the Yankees might be the
front-runner when you sit down really
well there their bullpen we play this
crazy bullpen game now and your starter
goes four innings maybe five and here
comes the pen and the Yankees pen is as
deep as anybody
yeah but how often are you going to the
pen you know because you've got to start
out you're getting in as a wild-card
team and you know you're gonna be
playing a few more games yeah they're
gonna live against it yeah and
everyone's leaving in it the obvious
force yeah the only thing I worry about
is can you really stay this hot for that
long that's what you worry about kind of
playing the odds on that we've seen what
happens with the NFL WNBA we've had some
protests there can you see a scenario
where anything comes up playoff wise in
baseball where there's any show of unity
protests whatever it might be with Major
League Baseball well I think it possibly
could I think what we see now with
social media it's not just one sport
it's athletes are way more United today
you know and so I can see that happening
I think when you look at what's
happening with it started with the NBA
and with the NFL but went to the NBA and
and it's we've had a guy in Oakland the
other day finally our first baseball
player that was kneeling down so it
could very easily happen because I think
it's they're more United
and ever before because of social media
use Harold Reynolds you can see him MLB
tonight and exclusively televising to
American League divisional Series games
probably would be in the wedding party
with a-rod I would imagine with JLo Wow
you guys come no we won't be invited I
know I'm not invited why you and there
I've been at odds remember what happened
no long time ago oh man I hope it's over
yeah he doesn't talk bad about you
anymore okay do you remember no I went
to Arlington when he was on the Rangers
and you're the one that said hey rod hey
he's really angry at you yeah because of
the Jeter stuff that he said to me when
we did an interview right and you're the
one that said hey it was my fault but
you said hey hey ROG he's not happy with
you and so we were going to Dallas and I
said I'm gonna go face-to-face with him
I go in the locker room yeah and there's
a couch there so a rods talking to my
clam I think so I got Palmeiro Canseco
Pudge I I got these guys are just there
on the kedai know what's happening they
know it's on I'm waiting for a rod and
all of a sudden I go he's talking to my
clam is it frankly forgot yeah man we
went there and then my clam walked away
and then I thought it was goat I thought
a rod was gonna punch me and so I had
Rob Dibble with me and I said hey Gibbs
if he hits me just get him off of me and
he said I got your back dibs was so
hoping he yes he um well I'm sorry I'm
sorry to interrupt your story yes and
I'm sorry to do this to you publicly but
okay but the day Nets have taken a vote
I'm not allowed to say this story
anymore
no we're giving Harold back his Gold
Glove oh we're doing it we're gonna
reward a Miss Gold Glove oh and I'm
sorry but you just can't have it why
it's not yours it's the right thing to
do but then for starters it's not yours
oh wow and Harold earned that it's his
Gold Glove he should have
I'm sorry this is the number-one show in
America thank you guys so back to a rod
nearly wanting to kill me so that's why
I don't think we ever got out of that
program I said some nice things so how
will you know I hope he does well
broadcasting and he seems like he's in
in love and I hope he's everything oh
yeah I just want him to hear the correct
thing but I did think he was gonna punch
me that day I did yeah
and you know the weird thing is I came
out of the out of the locker room and
I'm walking upstairs and who's walking
in but Scott Boras his agent and he goes
did you say hello to Alex I said oh yeah
I did and I go you're not happy no he
likes you no no he doesn't know see you
Scott yeah so work on a lot if you can
I'll work on it
Thanks always great to see and
congratulations on that Gold Gloves
Major League Baseball Network analyst
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience